Згідно з опитуваннями, 88 відсотків німців постійно купують ліки в одній аптеці - за місцем проживання.
Аптеки, у свою чергу, упродовж багатьох років отримують ліки у тих самих оптових продавців.
А ті - у фармацевтичних підприємств.
Така стала довіра, схоже, виправдана:
купити в німецькій аптеці відверто неякісні ліки майже неможливо.
За даними Аптекарської спілки ФРН, у 2018 році
підозра щодо маніпуляції чи підробки медичного препарату реєструвалась близько пів сотні разів.
Це приблизно один випадок на 100 мільйонів одиниць відпущених ліків.
У деякі роки жодна з таких підозр у Німеччині не підтверджувалася.
Тим більшого розголосу набувають випадки виявлення підробок чи неякісних ліків.
Взагалі уявити собі існування в Німеччині підпільних цехів для підробки ліків
на кшталт тих, які регулярно викривають в Україні, за словами фахівців, практично неможливо.
Якщо до ФРН і потрапляють неякісні ліки чи фальсифікат, то імпортовані.
Якщо ж у продажу виявляють справді неякісні або шкідливі ліки,
то в Німеччині це спричиняє великий скандал.
Так було влітку 2018 року.
Аптекар з міста Боттроп упродовж чотирьох років
готував та постачав хіміотерапевтичні розчини для крапельниць,
недодаючи лікувальну речовину.
Шахрая, який казково збагатився на онкохворих, засудили до 12 років позбавлення волі.
А контролі в аптеках стали ще більш ретельними.
Усього в Німеччині близько 20 тисяч аптек.
Міністерство охорони здоров'я, фармацевтичні спілки, фіскальні служби .
та інші контролюючі органи регулярно перевіряють аптекарів
Існує нагляд і за виробництвом, і за постачанням, і за вжитком ліків.
Свій внесок у контроль якості роблять і аптеки.
Кожна з них зобов’язана щоденно проводити обстеження одного медикамента за зовнішнім виглядом
і вносити свою оцінку у загальну базу.
Але найголовніше джерело інформації - самі пацієнти.
Скарги на якість ліків аптекарі мусять докладно протоколювати.
Рік тому захист від фармацевтичних підробок покращили у всьому Євросоюзі.
Головна зміна відбулась в упаковці.
Кожна одиниця медикаменту отримує від виробника унікальний QR-код.
Аптекар, перш ніж продати ліки, щоразу зчитує сканером дані з упаковки:
номер продукту, серію, виробника та партію.
Якщо Центральна база даних підтверджує, що упаковку з таким номером ще не продано,
вона віддається пацієнту.
Крім того, упаковка має захист від відкриття, аби запобігти заміні продукту всередині неї.
Одного разу відкривши коробку, знову закрити її, щоб виглядала як нова, не вдасться.
У разі виявлення підозрілого препарату "вмикається" система швидкого оповіщення.
Вона дозволяє повідомити одразу всі компетентні органи у Німеччині та ЄС.
Наскільки ефективно це працює, показав гучний скандал
із препаратом для зниження тиску валсартан,
який масово вироблявся в Китаї.
Аптекарі то в одному, то в іншому німецькому регіоні сигналізували,
що із традиційним медикаментом щось не так.
Тиждень - і  Європейська служба нагляду за якістю медикаментів
виявила у таблетках забруднення речовиною, що може викликати рак.
Виробник з Китаю, який дозволив собі необережність у виробництві,
мусив відкликати мільйони одиниць продукції.
Втім, попри ретельні контролі, час від часу і німці стають жертвами фармацевтичного шахрайства.
Щоправда, йдеться в таких випадках, як правило, про купівлю ліків не у класичній аптеці, а в інтернеті.
На першому місці серед підробок - віагра та інші засоби для покращення потенції.
Чоловіки, аби уникнути розмови із лікарем, купують їх на ненадійних сайтах і отримують недієві ліки.
Ціна одного кілограма віагри сягає на "чорному ринку" 100 тисяч євро.
Тому її так люблять підробляти кримінальні ділки.
Наразі німці купують через інтернет лише 1 відсоток ліків за рецептом і 17 відсотків - без рецепту .
Онлайн-продажі мають тенденцію до зростання.
Відповідно, випадків фальсифікату ставатиме більше, відзначають фахівці.